the women working here at this factory
in Afghanistan are sewing uniforms for
the military the political situation in
Afghanistan is highly unstable and
future prospects are uncertain female
workers are a relatively new addition to
the country's workforce and it's a break
with their traditional role as
homemakers just achieve anything up shut
up I worry about my future and what will
happen after 2014 when the international
community leaves Afghanistan this job
lets me feed my children but what will
happen if international aid is reduced
my children always pray for a good
future in Afghanistan valle de la mala
after the Taliban was ousted in 2001
women gained the right to vote some even
went into business on their own but they
have little trust in their government
let nobody hurt them now and the
government has no time for females they
discriminate against women and say women
should stay home to wash their clothes
look and easy as NATO speeds up its
withdrawal of troops it doesn't look
like Afghan women will be getting much
support from the international community
and if the Taliban is able to regain
power many women fear they will lose
their rights completely